okay but I'm often asked by callers by
Uno's random people I meet on the street
anyway I'm asked who do I think is
really like the worst person in the
Trump administration who do I really
find vile and disgusting whether it's a
current or former Trump official and
when I've been asked this I've been
pretty consistent right the most vile
repulsive current or former Trump
administration officials for me are
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the current press
secretary Golden Boy and Trump
son-in-law Jared Kushner and Nazi white
supremacist linked Sebastien Gorka just
if you don't remember him Sebastian
Gorka was a trump advisor he by all
indications was pushed out when chief of
staff John Kelly came in and realized
wait a second the presence of this guy
in our administration is completely
toxic and not surprisingly Fox News has
gone out and they've hired Sebastian
Gorka Sebastian Gorka reportedly has
sworn allegiance to the Nazi allied
Hungarian political party to that end
and he has denied this in his defense
sebastian Gorka has denied this but the
forward investigated this and found that
indeed Gorka appears to be tied to a
group called viz rend which according to
the American State Department was under
the direction of the German Nazi
government during World War two not
credible that Gorka has denied this
because the forward really did a good
job investigating it but in his defense
he has denied it and Sean Hannity had
the pleasure of introducing Sebastian
Gorka officially to the Fox News
audience saying on a recent show joining
us now is dr. Sebastian Gorka I can
officially announce today he is a Fox
News national security strategist
however not only is Gorka also Nazi
linked it's not really clear that Gorka
is actually a national security expert
either there's a funny quote from
Politico where they say several experts
interviewed by Politico puzzled over the
gap between the numerous
military academic credential credentials
listed by Gorka a political science PhD
who unfailingly uses the title doctor
and their unfamiliarity with his work
and views not really shocking right Fox
News has a very long history of having
so-called experts that aren't really
experts Fox News in hiring Sebastian
Gorka has hired a guy who once defended
Donald Trump staying totally silent
after a mosque was bombed because
according to Gorka it's possible that
liberals faked that bombing Gorka also
has in his occult and extensive track
record of these types of comments he
once asserted that people should really
stop criticizing white supremacists so
much so really it's a perfect fit for
Fox News I it's hard to imagine a better
hire for them and I used this phrase
yesterday talking about the Indiana
cross-check system which is I
inaccurately identifying 99% of the
voters to be removed from voter rolls I
said that's not a bug that's a feature
in other words that's exactly what
Republicans want the system to be doing
to be disproportionately D registering
non-white voters who are more likely to
be Democrats it applies here right
Gorka wasn't hired by Fox News despite
having this heinous track record of
horrible statements and ties to a
Hungarian Nazi Party he was hired
because those things count as positives
if you're being hired by Fox News and
Fox loves these types right they hired
Oliver North who gave weapons to Iran
with profits going to drug dealers in
Nicaragua they hired that racist police
officer Mark Fuhrman who played a role
in the now decades-old murder trial a
former football player Oh Jay Simpson I
think maybe they even hired g gordon
Liddy although I'm unless sure about
that when I'm thinking off the top of my
head anyway Congrats to Fox News
Congrats to Gorica really a match made
in heaven if you believe in that sort of
thing I guess